I just saw cocaine bear and of course I
had to find out how much of that movie
happened in real life and turns out
mostly just the cocaine and bear Parts
uh yeah this movie is completely based
on a real story and by completely I mean
like the first 20 minutes back in 1985
this dude was flying a big old shipment
of drugs over Kentucky only there were
too many drugs or maybe he got paranoid
and the cops were on his Trail I've read
differing opinions either way we know
this dude threw like 70 pounds worth of
cocaine out of his plane then he had to
pull a Loki and jump out of that plane
and his parachute was faulty though so
he ended up losing his life but the
weirdest part about that part of the
story my dude was named Andrew C
Thornton II that's like the worst drug
Smuggler name I've ever heard in my life
he sounds like an English butler who's
like the 500th in line for the throne or
something so anyway after sir Archibald
stuffington II launched like a Costco
serving of coke out of his plane it was
found by the most baller bear to ever
live The Bear Went like crazy on these
drugs this Wolf of Wall Street Yogi did
what pretty much anybody in the 80s
would do in this situation I think like
he went after it as hard as he possibly
could seriously they found 40 opened
containers of cocaine that this Bear
Went to Town on only this is where
things get really different from the
movie aside from the fact that the bear
was a boy in real life and is a mama
bear with a bunch of Cubs in the movie
see in the movie when the bear gets
super jacked on Tim Allen knows candy a
ton of hilarious and horrifying events
take place the bear gets all up on young
Han Solo Acts super trippy and then eats
like a ton of people and this is without
a doubt the better version of the story
okay so now it's time for another famous
edition of the things science corner so
kiddos what happens when a 175 pound
black bear eats pounds of cocaine does
the bear a go on a hilarious Rampage B
the bear Keels over almost immediately
or C gets a job on Wall Street it's
absolutely B the bear totally has an
overdose though a sequel where cocaine
bear becomes a surprisingly successful
stockbroker would make billions of
dollars dibs on the idea but even before
the internet which would have made
cocaine bear into a meme like
immediately this story was a huge deal
it became so legendary that it's weird
that this is the first movie made about
it and I really gotta hand it to the
police who handled the investigation
they knew that they had to preserve this
legend for history's sake like who cares
about losing the Library of Alexandria
we still have cocaine bear the chief
medical officer in his professional
opinion stated that this bear was
literally packed to the brim with
cocaine he then did the Lord's work by
having the bear stuffed by a taxidermist
who no doubt realized this is what his
entire life had been leading to so the
community then realized that they had a
real opportunity here they had to give
this bear the coolest name that they
possibly could no not cocaine bear
that's this Bear's title like Queen of
England or president of the United
States but more important they decided
that this creature would hence be dubbed
Pablo Escobar I mean that's a 10 out of
10 job right there probably the best
thing Kentucky would do until they gave
us Jennifer Lawrence in 1990 though
there is a great deal of argument over
whether it's spelled
e-s-c-o bear or e s k o bear like it's
been nearly 40 years and no agreement's
been reached the Civil War didn't last
nearly that long so clearly this is a
big deal so today my boy Pablo Americans
official cocaine bear is put up in the
Kentucky for Kentucky he is frequently
decorated with Hats chains and Christmas
decorations that I'm sure are treated
with as much care as the crown jewels
and there were also all kinds of places
where you could buy cocaine bear merch
that's got nothing to do with the movie
though now they're assuming that this
movie is going to be a big deal by just
advertising this baby everywhere have
you ever been to Oregon and seen how
like pretty much everywhere sells
Sasquatch merch yeah it's like that but
in a much smaller scale and I swear if
Elizabeth Banks ever makes a Sasquatch
movie Oregon is gonna lose its mind well
she might be too because it seems like
this marks a whole new era in her career
now while I was really hoping for an
equally crazy reason for Elizabeth Banks
to take this job like I was thinking she
drank a bunch of Ayahuasca in the desert
and a vision of Pablo Escobar appeared
to her in the wilderness and asked her
to tell his story but sadly it was a lot
more sensible than that evidently this
project was her way of dealing with the
chaotic world she found herself in
during the covid-19 pandemic the film
was just so bizarre that it resonated
with how bizarre she found the world it
was also a way for her to confront the
horrors of both the pandemic and climate
change and to her this is a movie about
how nature always wins in the end the
bear evidently resembles the eternal
struggle that man has with the coked up
rage monster that is planet Earth I
don't know if anyone else saw it that
way but whatever Elizabeth Banks you do
you she also just wanted to like make
something super fun for people to get
together and enjoy so that and her last
directing effort Charlie's Angels bombed
big time and she did not take that well
online so what did she have to lose
honestly and she does have a bit of a
spiritual connection with Pablo of the
changes the film made Banks said that
this is something of a hypothetical
Revenge story like she even has a
cocaine bear head in her office and I
really hope she talks to it like Hamlet
style every day wouldn't you honestly
I'm really hoping that this star on
Elizabeth Banks meme animals Cinematic
Universe like next up is harambe and
then Cecil the lion welcome to the new
MCU everybody